eurozone stability growth and economic
shock management are on the minds of
Europe's policymakers not least in light
of the market and currency instability
in Britain's case that followed brexit
finance ministers from seven member
states met with MEP S on the economic
affairs and budget committees to debate
the need for a euro area budget the icon
and the budget committees are working
together on an own initiative report
promoting converges and give incentives
to reforms absorb asymmetric and
symmetric shocks Parliament is currently
working on a report on building budget
capacity for the euro zone the zone
award wha-ho de neige emerged the Fox
initiative in the capacity of a polar
buddhafield order in food on a budget if
we really want to fight your skepticism
we need a Europe that can respond to
people's need that people feel that the
wage rate is not the only shock absorber
that the real wages are not only
flexible downwards but they can be
flexibly upwards and we need those
policies to be under democratic
accountability the report will fit into
a commission white paper plan for 2017
on completing European monetary union